deeply unsettling statistics here
today we're going to play a game of true
or false to learn more about gun control
personally i never
really used guns growing up never was a
thing in my family but
i'm not super anti people having guns so
much as like the automatic weapon thing
that's
clearly become a problem i like to use
the term gun safety instead of gun
control
growing up i knew like families that
like had like farms
you know and they would have guns and
then they would like
shoot one of those like clay pigeon type
stuff i know people who like
went hunting guns and that's more the
extent of what i know back in arizona i
know what my philosophies about gun
control and gun safety are but i don't
know that i know a lot about like the
laws
surrounding guns so i feel like i might
learn a lot true or false
rifles are the most common used gun in
u.s
murders oh in all u.s murders i'm gonna
say
thankful yeah because i think it's more
than a rifle right i don't know a lot
about guns
i'm gonna say false i'm gonna go with
false i think that we hear about
automatic weapons just because those are
used more for
mass killing but for murders i think
handgun wait assault rifles
a lot of the common ones are just like
little handguns like a pistol
in like u.s murders you know okay i'm
gonna go with true
because of assault rifles i just feel
like rifles are
probably very common guns but they're
hunting guns
so i'm going to say false i'm going to
go false i think there's other types of
guns but
so there you go that's exactly what you
were saying right hand crazy
yeah i feel weird celebrating getting
that right i'm not like hey yay
i'm like yeah okay i feel like just
because there's so much gun violence in
general
yeah when we hear about stuff it's the
the mass shooting exactly
um so i i feel like that's probably yeah
but that's super
interesting to hear because that's
exactly what you're saying where it's
like actually
there's even more of a violence than
assault rifles
after the u.s the second top gun owning
country is yemen ooh
i know i know nothing um i have no
reason to believe that's not true
i feel like most other developed
countries have
some form of gun control i don't have
like an answer
so i guess i'm just going to go true i'm
going to go true i'm going to say true
true i'm also realizing that that means
that we're number one
oh yeah we were both definitely just
guessing because yemen is very specific
in 2017 58 of women who were killed by
gun violence were killed by their
current or former intimate partner
ha yeah i know some people personally
it's very disturbing i don't know what
to say about it
58 is a lot that is true yeah because
honestly i would not be surprised if it
were even higher yeah really
i'm gonna go with true saying true 58
do you think it's higher that's a really
high percentage it's either true or
higher
i think that sadly yeah the crime of
passion type thing
a deeply tragic statistic that's hard to
rub me i don't know how to react
in every law show whenever there's like
uh a woman who is killed like they're
always like well let's where's the
husband where's the ex
i think i i don't know i don't know what
to say of the total 38
658 people who suffered a gun related
death in 2016
11 938 were suicides
that seems high i was going to say i
expected to be higher
all right split the difference and say
it's true
well dang i think that's false you think
it's false
i'm going to say false i think the
number of suicides is
higher in gun related deaths too high or
too low what do you think i think
suicides are probably
a variation of ways i mean it's horrible
either way i'm gonna say
it's true i'm guessing false gonna
go with true but it's not an educated
guess it's just something that
i sadly think is possible
it's double 22
000 deeply unsettling statistics here
whoa so i mean i was guessing the other
one yeah it's like actual guesses i
guess make sense
but the answers are wrong of the total
40 000 people imagine 40
000 people who died of gun related
deaths that's insane to me insane
thinking i guess true thinking that it
was a high number
but it's a way higher number than i
actually would have thought
saying we need gun reform and we need
mental health reform
hawaii has the lowest gun death rate in
the us
i see a lot of like shooting stories and
they're never
in hawaii that i haven't seen any in
hawaii but i'm also like is this a trick
question
i'm gonna say true yeah i'm skeptical
obviously
exactly hey i guess that's good
yeah that is a good a positive go hawaii
texas has the highest gun death rate in
the u.s
and some of the weakest gun laws i'm not
even i
that has to be yes right that's true i'm
gonna go true
yeah they also have open carry laws i
don't know if i would say open carry
laws are like
weak gun laws so i don't know but i i
feel like this could either be like a
trick
in that they are known for having guns
but maybe maybe i don't know
just makes sense makes sense i'm going
to say oh i'll agree with you all so
true
oh wow we were both very confident i
apologize
sorry texas i told you it was a trick
because we
no texans have guns yeah alaska has the
highest
gun death rate in the u.s and some of
the weakest gun laws whoa
wow that's very interesting i feel like
a lot of the things that i see
on the news aren't necessarily it's just
the surface of it
there's so much more that i have no idea
about
this makes me sad and feel a little
hopeless the fight
for sanity and safety and when your kids
are going to school with bulletproof
backpacks you know that your country is
not
doing enough i think the biggest
takeaway is for me i know i watch the
local news a lot and
most of what i know right now is what's
happening in los angeles but
it's interesting to be educated and to
know about the other places not only in
the country
but outside of america there is a common
desire
to stop gun deaths we just need to do
something hashtag do something
the 2020 elections are coming if you're
tired of gun deaths
get out and vote please vote
[Music]
you